Vous avez toujours voulu savoir si BigFoot existait, si les fantômes existaient.
Si les créatures surnaturelles *bafouillage* euh ok
Si les créatures surnaturelles tout court existaient.
Aujourd'hui on est sur Rake et on joue un p*tain de chasseur de créatures paranormaaaaleeees.
On est dans une p*tain de caravane et le but c'est de prouver que BigFoot
et ces créatures paranormales qui font flipper les gens existent, voilà parce qu'on a le doute, on a le doute.
Apparemment faut qu'on place des caméras.
Alors attends déjà je vais prendre ce qu'y a.
Alors où sont les caméras.. Elles sont là ok.
Attends mon gars il a pris 600 caméras !
il est allé dans un magasin GoPro il a dit "j'en veux 18" "c'est pour quoi monsieur ?" "pour prouver que BigFoot il existe"
"D'accord il est fou"
Voilà n'hésitez pas à vous abonner je fais aussi régulièrement des podcasts.
C'est parti alors on va pouvoir poser des caméras.
A mon avis, déjà on va en poser une sur le campement.
C'est quoi ce bruit ?
Ah d'accord, on a carrément un p*tain de cochon
Comment on fait pour installer une caméra ?
Qu'est ce qu'on a dans cette tente.. On a de la "Feed Wild" ok
de la nourriture pour attirer les monstres bien sûr
alors bigfoot on va l'attirer avec des malabars, ouiii
Un très bon chasseur
Alors j'aimerais bien mettre une caméra sur le cochon
Comment on ouvre ça
Ah attends, il est où le..il est où le cochon ?
Il s'est barré ? C'est un sketch
Il est où ?
Mais il fait quoi ?!
Mais reviens ! Reviens p*tain de cochon !
Je vais te kidnapper mon gars !
On est le chasseur le moins crédible de la planète quoi !
On a perdu notre cochon.. Voilà on commence hyper bien, bon on va mettre des caméras.
On va mettre des caméras là ! OK et de une !
Ah mais attends du coup on va pouvoir placer de la nourriture peut-être là dedans pour attirer les gens..
Mais oui ! On est malin !
Regardez le porc là qui court partout putain !
J'aimerais bien trouver où mettre les autres caméras !
Parce qu'avec une seule caméra, on va pas trop trouver BigFoot
On arrivera même pas à trouver une biche donc ça craint un peu.
En fait tous les points rouges sur la map, c'est les endroits où je peux mettre des caméras.
On va en mettre le plus possible mon gars, sinon on va se faire défoncer
Hop une de plus !
C'est déjà une mission de trouver sur quel arbre mettre les caméras quoi !
Regardez, sur la map je suis sur le point rouge, il est où ?
Il est là.. Bah je suis débile !
Voilà ! On est bien !
Ecoutez je vous propose un truc très très simple
On va retourner au campement et on va passer le jour !
On va sortir la nuit avec notre fusil et on va.. Oh le porc est tombé dans le piège !
Oh regardez le con ! On va pouvoir lui mettre une caméra !
Ah bah non on peut pas en mettre plus de 5 ! On est tellement baisé !
Oh non ! Une caméra sur le porc ça aurait été génial !
BigFoot il mange quoi ? Il mange pas du KFC, il mange du porc !
Bon c'est pas grave, on prend le fusil on retourne dans la caravane ! Et on zappe la journée !
Oh p*tain ! Ambiance au max !
Oh regardez c'est ça qu'on cherche ! Voyez on a eu des preuves là !
Est-ce qu'on peut accéder à nos caméras ?.. Ouais !
On peut bouger en plus avec c'est trop bien mec !
Caméra suivante !.. Y a rien on voit rien on va pas se mentir.
Caméra 3, y a rien du tout..
Quand c'est rouge ça veut dire quoi ? Ca veut dire qu'y a du bruit ?
Ouais mais c'est le porc qui tourne autour.
Vous savez quoi ? On va aller le buter ! Puis on va revenir dans la caravane.
Il est où ?.. Il est où le porc ?
Woooh ! Y a du bruit ! Qui a fait du bruit ?
Allo ?! Attends il me fait flipper ce porc là !
En journée il faisait le mec timide et tout, mais en vrai il est carrément vénère !
Attends mais c'est le porc ou c'est BigFoot qui rode là ?
C'est un porc ! Il est où ? Il me vénère mon gars ! Il est en train de sabauter le chasse le con !
Allez, on re-rentre dans la caravane. On peut fermer la porte ou pas ?
Oui ! C'est toujours plus correct !
Y a rien... Y a pas de mouvement, rien du tout mec. C'est chaud.
A part le porc ! Oh p*tain il est là mec ! Alors là, tu vas regretter d'avoir voulu me narguer !
Où qu'il est le porc ?! Où qu'il est ?!
Oh p*tain merde. Là c'est sûr je me suis fait repérer par BigFoot.
Il va se ramener il chausse du 68. Au moins on a chassé le porc on est tranquille !
Cam 5.. Elle est cassée ?!
Attends le monstre il est carrément intelligent il casse mes caméras !
J'suis choqué !
Oh y a du bruit là. Y a du bruit mec.. C'est un porc qui nous montre son cul !!
Mais c'est pas possible ! Demain dans la journée j'irai tous les buter !
Regarde, voilà ! Il nous montre son cul encore...
Alors toi... Il est où ?! Il est parti là ?!
Tu voles le nourriture de qui comme ça ?! Putain !
Je vous jure il est parti voler de la nourriture ! C'est là où y avait les sacs de graines !
Oh ouais il tombe dans le piège mec ... !
Oui ! Oh le con !
Vas-y je vais lui mettre une caméra dessus !
Vas-y met-toi bien ! Oh regardez-le !
Je le déteste ce sale porc.
Alors du coup caméra 5 logiquement on est sur le porc.
Eh oui ! C'est bon ça !
C'est en restant sur le porc qu'on trouvera le monstre. Parce que le monstre il bouffe quoi ?
Il bouffe des porcs.
J'ose même pas compter le nombre de fois où j'ai dit le mot porc dans cette vidéo.
Toujours rien. Absence totale de monstre. Bah écoutez ce porc ne nous mène nul part.
Je propose un truc, on porte nos balls et si BigFoot existe on va lui dire bonjour !
On voit rien, on voit rien ! C'est terrible !
C'est quoi ce bruit ?
Là y a une caméra à nous. On va aller un peu plus loin.
Attends j'ai trop envie de trouver ce monstre là !
Eh oh !! Montre toi un peu là !
Y a un truc qui  a bougé ! Là bas y a un truc qui a bougé dans les fougères !
Y a un bruit.. Y a un bruit !
Y a un truc qui marche.. C'est un porc c'est sûr.
On a vu tellement de porcs j'y crois plus une seconde aux monstres !
C'est un porc ! Regardez !
Eh oh ! Est ce que t'es là ?
AAHH !
Wooooh ! La caravane ! 'Gitanoo pom pom podom, cette caravane qui bat dans ma peau'
Oh c'est terrible cette fois.
Il m'a défoncé c'était un alien ! C'est pas BigFoot, c'était E.T !
Oh putain mec... C'est sérieux ce qu'on vient de voir ?
M'en bats les couilles je vais dans cette caravane j'y reste jusqu'à la fin de ma vie. *rire*
Je vais rester avec mes porcs finalement ma vie était super.
Et comment je fais pour le capturer, ça mange quoi un alien ?
C'est vrai ça ! Je veux bien mettre de la bouffe dans la cage là mais qu'est ce qu'il mange ?
Sûrement pas des graines.
Je vais laisser les graines, avec un peu de chance on va retrouver l'alien à quatre pattes en train de les manger.
Ce serait ultra humiliant pour lui.
L'alien est pas con, là où il y a des caméras il y va pas ! C'est sûr hein !
Il nous reste 26 balles on va pouvoir y aller.
Putain j'ai quand même des doutes. *rire*
C'est pas qu'il m'a fait peur mais un peu quand même.
Bon allez, on met du Desktop dans lévier bim bam boum et on part.
Eh montre toi là ! T'as intérêt à te montrer toi qui vient d'une autre planète !
J'arrive pas à faire les accents, je mélange tous les accents du monde.
On va retourner là-bas. On est sur le bon chemin, on va retourner en hauteur, dans le petit spot où on était.
AAHHH
Eh mec t'es mort ! T'es mort !
Tu sais pas par qui j'ai été élevé moi ! Mon père m'a endurci... au krav maga !
On tuera ce truc, on le dépessera et on vendra sa peau hyper cher sur Ebay, y aura toujours un mec chelou pour acheter ça.
*bruit de monstre*
Mais c'est pas possible ! Il est fort le con, je l'entends pas venir !
Attends vite faut que j'aille au truc en hauteur ! Je vais mourir mec, vite !
OK c'est bon ! Là on est safe ! Ose venir toucher ce bois ! Ca porte chance tu devrais venir hein.
Il est pas loin. Je suis en train de me chier dessus, je deviens parano.
Voyez les deux points verts sur la carte ? Je pense qu'il est entre les deux.
Eh on est des bonhommes on va aller voir direct !
Y a un bruit. C'est un sanglier ?
Une seule solution... la manifestation... non ! Aller voir !
Une biche ! *coup de feu* Putain !
Attends, on va se barrer dans le doute, ça va peut-être attier l'alien.
Aucun signe de lui... Il est fort !
OOOHH ! Putain ! Mais c'est abusé mec !
Faudrait que je mette une caméra à 360° sur moi et que je me balade.. ou sur le porc !
Et là c'est sûr y aurait au moins une prise de lui.
Bon alors on est de retour sur cette .. étagère, à chaque fois qu'il nous a tapé c'était ici !
On dirait que c'est son étagère, qu'il a mis son odeur dessus et qu'il veut pas qu'on mette la notre.
Donc je peux le comprendre, malheureusement je suis pas d'accord.
Si on fait un 360° no scop across map, y avait un echance de le tuer.
Attends y a un ptit bunker, c'est super ça ! Ah mais attends il peut carrément nous choper le cou !
La pire cachette du monde, ça fait encore plus flipper d'être là-dedans que d'être dans rien.
-Essaye d'attirer un monstre-
Des fois ça marche hein, une fois un lapin s'est pointé après avoir dit ça.
Mon gars on va revenir au campement il sera parti avec la caravane tranquillement.
On va la retrouver sur Le bon coin demain
*bruit de pas*
OH ! Il est là !
Oh putain quand je regarde la map ! T'es un gros lâche !
T'es un gros lâche !
T'es un grommash ! Allez !
Il commence à me vénère cette alien à nous attaquer dès qu'on le voit pas !
*bruit de pas*
Oh non j'avais sorti le fusil ! Je l'avais sorti ! J'suis vénère !
Il est pas loin du campement là mec !
Le campement est jsute là les gars !
*coup de feu*
Ooohh !
C'est bon la chasse a été bonne ! Pourquoi chasser un alien quand on peut buter un porc ?!
Allez c'est bon la chasse est terminée ! Moi je me casse.
Pourquoi on se fait chier à chasser un putain d'alien sans déconner ?
C'est un écran noir. C'est fini ? C'est la fin, on l'a pas eu, j'suis vénère !
Donc conclusion de la vidéo, on a pas réussi à avoir l'alien et en plus on a tué une bête qui a nourri l'alien !
Ce qui explique pourquoi on retrouve cette putain de bête à 3 mètres de là où on l'avait butée !
Moi j'arrête la chasse c'est pas pour moi je me tire.
Bon les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur Rake j'espère que ça vous a plu !
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo comme d'habitude.
Je suis dégouté je voulais trop buter cet alien, en plus c'est vraiment un fourbe
tu marches et t'entends d'un coup *imitation de bruits de pas et de monstre*
Meilleure imitation du YoutubeGame
Voilà j'ai la haine, on a pas eu notre diplôme de chasseur, c'est un échec !
Allez à très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez vous bien !
Ciao tout le monde ! Peace !